do you think stalin really knew that
it's gonna fall apart why would somebody
like stalin trust somebody like hitler
but why did he blunder so bad not to
um read the intelligence that was coming
his way oh the troops are amassing on
the border of the soviet union he didn't
trust his own intelligence apparatus
here's one one example uh
um
there was a german communist um who
uh who went on the ground when hitler
took over and he would he went to japan
as a journalist his name is richard
zorger
and godzilla had really really good into
intel
about what the
japanese would do and not do
and it i forgot exactly what it was but
uh it was it came to moscow and stalin
totally totally ignored it
and and when zorga was uh
uh captured by the
uh by the japanese uh the soviet union
denied that uh
he was one of there so he was executed
uh that the paranoia again
uh
does a lot of damage we when you don't
when you don't believe your own
intelligence apparatus why
why bother having one
yeah i mean there
but i'm sure there's contradictory
information coming in from the
intelligence apparatus so it's difficult
i mean first of all nobody likes to be
disagreed with especially when you get
become more and more powerful and then
the intelligence apparatus is probably
giving you information you don't like
but it's often
negative information about yeah uh
basically information that
says that the decisions you made in the
past
are not great decisions and that's a
difficult truth to deal with yeah
so there you know in the modern times if
we hop around briefly is uh vladimir
putin
has been
um not happy with the intelligence of
the fsb thereby at least if you read the
news right
choosing
uh to put more priority to the gru for
the intelligence in ukraine right
um
but i guess i i suppose the same story
happens there as this throughout history
is paranoia i i give you uh an example
that
that comes
from a very reliable source
uh
and that my my best german friend
uh worked as a chemist in the
anastasi east german intelligence
and uh
he
eventually uh he he rose to the rank of
major and was in charge of
the forgery department
it's very likely that he made passports
that i used to travel
he was aware that there was intelligence
that that was uh that was collected the
study was really good they had about a
thousand people in west germany
undercover agents uh some of them in
government and the central committee of
the party and the decision makers
ignored it because it didn't quite fit
in their worldview it didn't quite fit
into their plans
so uh and and one one delicious uh
um thing that i just want to add on to
this when when gorbachev uh
um wrote his book about perestroika and
glasnost
uh
the the east german uh uh rulers did not
like it they were much much more
orthodox so
they had to print the books in
translation
guess where they wound up
they were in the piled up in the
hallways of the stasi
they bought the entire
print run
you